[Music]
[Applause]
reggie miller hall of famer turner
sports nba
analyst a lot to get to reg
let me hit you with the early poll
question that we had mclovin you want to
give reg the first hour poll question
first our poll question whose career
would you rather have robert orry or
chris webber
wow uh
well that is a tough one that's a great
question
i i guess seven championships
kind of trumps everything right is it
seven or six seven championships seven
a lot of big shots for robert dorey but
think about
the culture change chris webber was a
part of
being part of the fab five in michigan
because you're
incompetencing the whole career right
not just nba yeah
yeah college too i like c webb's career
obviously he didn't
doesn't have a championship to back it
up but a hell of a career for c
webb you could not go wrong with either
or
um but seven championships ring that's
hard to turn down
that's hard would you rather have robert
orry's career
or yours taking mine
okay all right i'm just i'm taking mine
i know i don't have any chips to show
for it but
it was all about the struggle for me all
about the struggle to win one
and i will never change my career for
anyone's
because that's to me that's what it was
all about
now is robert doria hall of famer yes
i really do believe so really and if you
think about it
you could take away a chip from tim
duncan
and you probably could take a chip away
from kobe if it wasn't for the fact
of big shots by robert dorey i do
believe he's a hall of famer and if you
look at some of the guys that are
currently getting in that don't have
gaudy numbers
i mean ben wallace was a great defender
but he doesn't have gaudy numbers
ben wallace is going in this year uh de
company mutumbo
great defensive player defensive player
of the year but not gaudy numbers
in the hall of fame robert orry should
be in the hall of fame
yeah i as much as i like ben i don't
think he's a hall of famer
ben wallace i think he was a really good
player
he was a a key player for you know some
good teams
but um i i just don't see i was a hall
of famer no
no i do i don't like chris bosh was a
wonderful player in toronto he was the
third person in miami
i know health issues but he was second
team all nba one time and that's it
like i i don't i don't know how we
judge and maybe my bar is too high here
reg you know when it comes to the hall
of fame but
i don't know i don't i don't want to
apologize for being
kind of tough on you know the
requirements i don't want to demean ben
wallace
you know dikembe you want to put him in
the hall of fame you want to put ben in
there boston i mean that's fine
i guess i just trying to understand the
criteria here
i think the criteria you're thinking
about
is in terms of other hall of fames
because it's very difficult
to get into major league baseball's hall
of fame very tough
to get into the nfl i think the nba
criteria of getting in is not as high
and i think they do encompass
a person's body of work going back to
college too
so i i think when i look at ben
wallace's career
again not gaudy numbers but was on great
teams
championship teams in detroit he was the
head of the snake
defensively for that team um
he was a couple times defensive player
of the year i believe yeah
i think he deserves now again i've gone
against these guys head to head so i'm a
little biased because
i've seen their body of work up close
but is derrick fisher a hall of famer
no he got he got five titles five titles
he's played in more playoff games than
anybody in nba history
he's he's got three thousand twenty five
hundred more points than robert orri
does
made some big shots yes so i don't know
i just
throw that out there throw that out
there steve kerr is going into the hall
of fame isn't he
well wow he's got what coach and player
basketball
he's got so he's got eight rings
yeah i think so right five and live as a
player
three as a coach he's a he's going in as
a hall of famer
combination he's going into hall of
famer as a coach yeah
as a coach he'll go in his hall of famer
uh he probably won't go in as a player
but they just they would just say steve
kerr hall of famer
but they would designate him as a coach
going into i think he will go
in as he i think he'll go in as a coach
but he's still a hall of famer
whether you're a coach or a player oh
yeah
yeah i don't know if you could start
your team with
kobe duncan kg
what era what rules
1995.
tim duncan okay i said the same thing
2015.
kobe bryant yeah that's what i said too
kobe would learn to well yes
he's student of the game he's going to
learn to be great in today's nba would
he be a volume three-point shooter
kobe yeah he was a great i thought he
was a great shooter anyways
yeah but yeah he would be a volume he
would be a volume scorer
because i don't want to label him as a
shooter because
kobe can give you buckets so he would be
a volume scorer as
very much as he was throughout his
career better in-game dunker
kobe or jordan
uh jordan man i'd looked at some
highlights of kobe
yeah i would say this kobe was probably
more artistic because he had the great
reverse dunks
yeah that jordan never had um
but jordan used to embarrass you on some
of them dunks that
to me the all-time classic jordan dunk
is the one
against the knicks in the garden when
he's going baseline
makes the other way and then continues
to go baseline
and just pipes on i don't know if that's
patrick or
uh i don't know who it looks like all of
the new york knicks that's probably my
best dunk ever of michael jordan did did
jordan ever get you
well i was guarding him so i left he
blew
so i got the wrath of it from dale and
antonio
like rich keep them in front of you i'm
like i'm sending them to hell
see you never got posterized because you
weren't the guy who was going up to try
to block right
absolutely not i was smart enough that's
their job is to protect the rim
not mine did you posterize anybody with
a dunk
i'm sure there's someone i got you sure
there has to be someone
you should remember you should remember
like a two-hander down the lane
against the knicks yes mclevin
satan look it up against the knicks in
the playoffs i did
i got charles oakley and charles smith i
did i got
them in the playoffs they must hold up
oh
yes i did against the nets the new
jersey nets
in the overtime game my last year
or second to last year that sent the
game to overtime i dunked on the whole
next team
it's the most famous dunk of mine ever
it's my last dunk actually
yeah paulie yeah he dunked right in uh
kmart's mug kenyon martin
yes thank you do you think that they
they had to be so surprised they're like
this this dude ain't jumping like like
carrie kittles is going this guy can't
jump
hold up i was just as surprised
you should see jason kidd's face he's
like
what what did reg just do
hey i will tell you this when i started
to go up i heard the theme
i heard the theme music i believe i can
fly
i believe i can touch this guy
i'm telling you i felt what that was
going on you're holding on to the rim
you've never been up that high before
and what's funny about that mark jackson
was at the game
just to come watch us play and i
remember after the dunk
and the timeout and i walk you back to
the bench and his seats were kind of
behind our bench
and i'm walking and he's just shaking
his head and i'm giving him one of these
looks like
you remember this you remember this mark
it was hilarious uh he's reggie miller
the hall of famer
uh how concerned would you be if you're
the lakers with
steph curry here that is a nuclear bomb
that can go off
at any time um
look the let's face it the lakers are
the better team
they're the bigger team um
championship experience but so do golden
state warriors
but steph curry the way he has played
all season and especially the last
two months he can explode and
in a one game series if he gets hot
it look i will say this for the lakers
they have a lot of
wing defenders that they're going to
throw at him dennis schroeder
kentavious caldwell pope caruso will get
some time on him
and if need be lebron james if it's you
know
last possession of of the possible game
so
it's the lakers to lose they should win
it
but steph scares me
the lakers do well against steph they're
two teams that seem to do well clippers
and lakers do well they have length and
i think
you know i i'm gonna let whoever you
know we're gonna pick
somebody if that guy gets 30 35 fine
i can't let steph have you know over 35.
i just
i can't and and then if if it's the
other guys who beat us
you know okay but i i'm not gonna i'm
gonna make sure steph has to give the
ball up a little bit
and you know for the lakers too
when anthony davis was in the new
orleans
he used to dominate golden state during
the playoffs
and i just don't think they have a
match-up form as great as draymond green
is he has given up six or seven inches
and a lot of length going against a.d so
ad should have a field
day versus golden state but
i just don't think they have enough
scoring unless
wiggins reverts back and gives them 25
or 30.
uh jordan poole has played great coming
off the bench for them had a career high
i believe 38
a few games ago i just don't think they
can
generate enough scoring against the
number one rated
defensive team in the lakers
but looking at the lakers it feels like
if you don't get them early
then you're in trouble because i think
once they
get back into the rhythm here then
they're going to be less vulnerable here
do you do you feel that way or do you
think the health of lebron and
anthony davis are going to be sort of a
cloud hanging over this team
you know the entire postseason i think
it's always going to be a question mark
we just saw within the last five minutes
of that pelicans game
a little bit of a tweak to the ankle of
lebron
now coach vogel came out and said he's
okay he's good to go
but what else is he going to say oh he
taught you know he turned his ankle
again
so he's got to put that out i think
health and concern will always follow
these lakers throughout these playoffs
but it's funny how teams in the western
conference
were kind of dodging a little bit oh boy
not to fall in the lakers path um denver
did it
the clippers did it the clippers yeah
the clippers did it um
but i will say this i feel bad for
phoenix
because phoenix is i mean great year
chris paul is an mvp candidate
devin booker has been ridiculous monty
williams will probably win
coach of the year and what how are you
rewarded
you've had the best record a resurgence
in the valley of the sun
and you were rewarded by playing the
world champs possibly knock on wood
in the first round come on who else is
dangerous
in the west or just in general just in
general like just say hey
here's a team that just keep an eye on
health if they're healthy and this is a
scary first-round matchup in the east
how did milwaukee draw miami
miami ousted them last year in the
playoffs
they know how to play giannis
now to milwaukee's credit i think
they've done a great job of going out
and getting some pieces
i think that will help them getting drew
holliday
and pj tucker two tough guys two
defensive minded guys that are going to
help giannis
in the playoffs but miami is a team
that has championship aspirations
we saw them get to the finals if they
can find that shooting touch because
their defense has been really good
bam has been playing great jimmy butler
has to stay healthy
he's been up and down all year with
health but when he's right
when those shooters are right hiro and
duncan
this is a scary team to watch it's
almost a pickham series for me i know
milwaukee's the third seat but to me
that's a pick em series
if you did your mvp vote today who who
would get it
i i'm voting for steph okay
i know jokic will win
and rightfully so he's played every game
and he's had unbelievable numbers
he'll win it but my mvp
no one expected golden state when they
heard the news that clay torres
his achilles that they were going to be
in this position
and he think about other than draymond
i know wiggins is good kelly ubrey got
off to who else is on
who beigemore
i know your number two pick wise ben
went down
about a month and a half ago so they
steve kerr has found ways
to patchwork this team and now
they're in the playing game he is my mvp
his last two months have been ridiculous
that's ridiculous what he's done
video game if you could have robert
orry's career or steve nash's career
steve nash two-time mvp yeah kind of
changed the game
i'm gonna go with steve nash yeah that
was my i know championships are great
don't get me wrong but to be a baller
and to be the best player on the team
and to be the leader and to be a face of
a nation to and with canada too
for you know for a long while i'm taking
steve nash okay
robert orry vince carter
now i might have to go with lava glory
but half man half amazing
he started the basketball revolution
along with steve nash for canada when he
was up in toronto
but seven ships i mean
robert always needs to be in the hall of
fame i know i get where you're going
rob rory needs to be in the hall of fame
theodore man but
okay iverson robert orri
oh come on stop it iverson
that's easy he's a cult hero yeah it's
true
he is a cult hero he he's like uh shaq
wilt steph they a jordan
they change things they change the
culture of things the way we perceive
things
i'm going with ai i'll leave you with
this
how much of you wanted to hear kobe give
that speech yes uh saturday
well you know we heard jordan's speech
right when he went you know he took
names and went after guys yeah i think
we would have seen kind of the same
thing
you think he would have rose to the
audience yes
and then some see i thought he would
have roasted
kg and duncan
i think he probably would have told a
story about mj2 because i'm sure mj
he would have asked mj to stand up for
him as well
and just see them side by side because
they will forever be linked because they
are the two best shooting guards
this game has ever seen and just to see
them side by side
would have been really cool um because
of how much
kobe looked up to his airness
um but vanessa was fantastic oh my god
i i i i don't know how
i i don't know how she she does it how
she did it at the
memorial at staples which was
that was too soon for me and then
this it's she was fantastic i got more
emotional than she did like she held her
composure and i'm going
oh man this is hitting me hard
it really is uh it's it's tough
it really is because uh i'm glad we're
starting to get a sense
and see how kobe
was away from the court you know and
we're getting a better glimpse of that
because all we see was
win win win by any means necessary go
right through you
and rightfully so because you know play
haven't played against him that's how he
was
but i kind of knew kobe away from the
court
and how vanessa and his and
the family have kind of made him more
human is
has been fantastic along with gigi i
mean
just great absolutely great great talk
to you bud
um you're always the best theodore we'll
uh we'll talk soon once again you would
have your career over robert dory's
right yeah
i love you big shot but you're getting
this and this
i have big shots too i just don't have
these
i don't have these but i can go big shot
for big shot with you
okay but can i have one of these
you're a better shooter than robert dory
man come on stop it
i just stopped like stand still
stand still kick out robert orry
you put you like this he will come to me
for shooting
okay and they're coming to me for
shooting there's a lot of guys who would
uh thank you buddy talk to you soon
you're the best theodore i love you dan
that's uh reggie aloysius miller jr iii
we're back after this in the dan patrick
show